[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time this
is my little
humble book review show
so the book we're talking about today is
another one that i picked up uh just
kind of randomly at a used bookstore and
it's an author we've covered before it's
an author i've read before
this is richard layman and this book is
called body rides now this was actually
one that i hadn't heard of
it was published by leisure books as a
lot of his stuff was um particularly
after he passed away i feel like they
released a lot of his uh books because i
think he died in 2001 if i'm not
mistaken so this came out in 2004 but
when you read the story um i'm pretty
sure that it was written like back in
the 90s because i think it's actually
set in 1995 i want to say you know some
people have cellular phones but it's you
know they're kind of like
it's not something that's really
ubiquitous uh you know there's still
video stores that kind of stuff because
that actually like figures into the plot
so remember what i said about the last
richard lehman book that i talked about
which which was uh come out tonight and
remember how i said i'd read richard
lehman before so i know that he's very
well known for you know he's very well
known for being a quote unquote splatter
punk author so you know a lot of his
stuff is like really really over the top
violent gory stuff like that and there's
also a lot of smut this one is kind of
like there's some violence and stuff but
it's mostly like in torture and stuff
but that's toward the end this one is
mostly just smut um which there's
nothing wrong with that i'm just saying
that
uh so much so that i don't know if i
would actually call this a
straightforward horror novel this is
more like an erotic
crime thriller sorta
even though the whole middle section
uh not gonna lie probably could have
been excised because the whole middle
part is basically like a rom-com it's so
weird this is such a weird book it's
ridiculous
it's kind of fun
um i kind of i was curious to see like
after i read it because i'm reading it
and like some like while i was reading
it sometimes like i was like what the
actual [ __ ] in my reading was like where
is this going and it's like why is this
dude just like so obsessed with nipples
man so many nipples i mean everyone's
nipples are described
in
just exhaustive detail so it's you know
if that's your thing then
this is definitely the book for you but
yeah like so remember that i said like
when i did come out tonight
i was talking about sorry about the
banging in the background that's pookie
she figured out how to bang the cabinet
doors back there so i can't really get
her stuff she's just kind of like that's
that's her new thing but remember when i
was talking about come out tonight when
i said the book was essentially like
really really adolescent and i said well
you know i can't remember exactly what i
said but i was kind of like you know i
guess i'll let it slide because the main
characters were two adolescent boys and
they found this
grown woman who had been i think she'd
been like you know raped and left for
dead and stuff and they were kind of
like well we're going to help her but
also we need to like peek at her titties
so it was that kind of thing so it's
just kind of like gross but they're
teenage boys so what do you expect now
this one though has almost the same it's
not exactly the same but it's a similar
kind of setup except in this case like
the main character is a grown-ass man
he's like 28 years old and but he just
thinks like an adolescent boy this reads
very much
like an adolescent boy's
very very detailed specific and expanded
like sexual fantasy but put into novel
form and like i said because this is
like supposed to be a grown-ass man so
at some time so sometimes i was reading
this so i'm just saying that
and i think this is true of a lot of
richard layman's books i mean he's r he
wrote a [ __ ] ton uh and i've only read
probably like a smattering of them so
i'm not like an expert by any means but
from what i've read of other people's
like reviews of his stuff basically you
just have to really like suspend your
disbelief because
i kind of feel like a lot of other
authors if they wrote stuff like this
like no one would get away with it
because people like come on man it's
like nobody acts like that nobody thinks
like that like the people in this book
specifically like the the main character
like the stuff that he thinks and says
and particularly the women and i think i
brought this up like when i was talking
about come out tonight too i'm like the
women characters do and say things that
no woman on earth would ever do like in
real life uh so i said this is kind of
like definitely it's like a male fantasy
type of uh situation which i'll get into
a minute because i seriously i gotta
spoil this one because there's some
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just you can't believe it and
actually this one i kind of feel like
the last um when i did come out tonight
i don't think that's you know i remember
kind of what happened in that but i
remember it not really having a
supernatural component this one does
so not only um are the characters
uh and their actions
kind of unbelievable but there's also
like an additional you know suspension
of disbelief necessary because there's
also a supernatural element even though
i will say like the supernatural element
like the concept of this is actually
pretty cool but i would ding it for i
kind of feel like it's such a cool
concept that i wish it had been
developed more
instead of
you know just kind of going off on these
sexual fantasy digressions um and i was
like well can we get back to like the
supernatural [ __ ] because that's like
kind of a cool idea and there's a lot
you could do with that there is some
stuff done with it but i kind of feel
like it needed to be expanded more
because this is almost like this is a
very very strange book it's almost kind
of like
i don't even know how i describe it's
almost like a weird
like road trip i don't know it's it's
not it's not like structured i kind of
feel like it's not structured like a
regular narrative novel like it's
narrative like [ __ ] happens and then
[ __ ] happens after that so there's like
a plot but i don't know it's just really
weird so maybe if i describe what
happens in it like you'll see what i'm
talking about
so the main character
is this dude named neil darden and this
is when they said like his last name i
was all i could think of was darden
restaurants which i don't know if you
know but that's the company that owns
like olive garden and a bunch of other
ones so so the whole time i was just
thinking olive garden man but yeah so uh
neil lives in la and like i said this is
set in the mid-90s i think
and he is
really um probably overly concerned
about because at the beginning of the
book he goes back to the video store
like after it's closed he's going to
drop some movies off because he's like
oh well you know i don't want to get a
fine or whatever even though i'm pretty
sure if you drop them off after it
closes you get to find anyway so i don't
know why you would just wait just wait
till the morning if he's so scared of
going out so his inner monologue is
he's like so terrified of going to the
video store in the middle of the night
and thinking he's going to get shot by
quote-unquote gang-bangers and i'm just
kind of like
like i know la is like a dangerous city
and everything like that but i'm like
really i mean are you really so scared
to just like drive like a mile and drop
videos off and then go home that he has
to like carry his you know loaded gun
everywhere and he's just like so scared
why am i doing this oh my god and it's
just i'm kind of like oh okay i'm not
from la so i can't really say but it
just seemed a little a little over the
top
so while he's on his way to the video
store and it's like midnight or whatever
time it is he hears a woman screaming
so again so like i said it's very much
like come out tonight where he just
stumbles across like a damsel in
distress essentially
so he sees a naked woman of course and
she's tied to a tree or a pole or
something like that and there's this
dude who is like torturing her i guess
he's like plier and like
you know doing her nipples with pliers
and all this kind of stuff like outside
you know what i mean but like under an
overpass like there's nobody around
and so he um being like woo i'm a hero i
have a loaded gun because i was so
scared of gangbanger shooting me like in
a drive-by
that he intervenes
and he shoots the perpetrator
and he thinks he kills him
uh but then so he goes and like helps
the woman who she hasn't been raped but
she's been like tortured and she's kind
of [ __ ] up she's okay but i mean she's
you know her nipples are all [ __ ] up
because there's a lot of nipples in this
book like i said um one of the one of
the funniest reviews i can't take credit
for this but one of the funniest reviews
on goodreads of this book
was that
they said it's a shame i'm paraphrasing
but they said it's a shame that you know
how there's that urban legend that the
inuit have like through 200 words for
snow or something like that it's like
it's too bad that the english language
only has one word for nipple because
because richard layman would could have
really used like a lot more like words
for nipple because there's a lot of
nipple action to this every single like
i said every single female character's
nipples are described like exhausted
whatever their nipples are up to he's
gonna tell you i'm just telling you that
right now so it's like it's funny but
you know i don't know it's just funny to
me
so uh so yeah so he saves this woman
because he thinks that he kills her
attacker
and she's like kind of injured but not
too bad and of course like while he's
saving her he's like checking her out
because she's naked you know and it's a
dude what are you gonna do um like i
said same kind of thing that happened
and come out tonight even though those
were adolescent boys and like i said
this is a 28 year old man
who i think he's a screenwriter yeah
he's a screenwriter
so he basically so he takes her back to
her house and it turns out that she's
married to this like big sort of famous
actor and so she lives in this like big
huge massive uh house you know with a
big pool and everything so she
essentially like invites him in and
she's like super nice like totally
flirting with him and all this other
because of course she is and uh even
though he says that he has a girlfriend
which he does uh his girlfriend's name
is marta and she is um i guess she works
for an airline so she's like gone at
night you know what i mean and so he's
kind of like well i can't he really
wants to do something with her and he's
basically like falls in love with her
like immediately which happens uh a lot
in this book actually now that i'm
thinking about it every single again
every single woman that he meets i'm
pretty sure every single woman that he
meets like falls desperately in love
with him like in the first five minutes
which like i said is a very
it's a very male fantasy kind of like
okay that's not really what's gonna
happen in real life but it's a book it's
fine okay so this woman's name is elise
and she basically says well i want to
thank you so much for saving my life
and basically everything that's mine is
yours i'm going to put you in my will
it's like she goes way over the top
right so he's like hanging out in the
house she makes him she kind of like
bullies him but to stay in a little bit
he takes a [ __ ] but he's not you know he
he's kind of like he he falls in love
with her like i said uh so he's not too
upset about staying there he doesn't
have sex with her or anything but he
thinks about it for sure but yeah he's
like take a shower they have a drink and
stuff and then she's like oh yeah you're
going on my well and all this other
stuff and she's like oh and by the way
um i have something for you now this is
where the supernatural element comes in
she has this bracelet
and it's like a big like heavy gold
bracelet that looks like a snake or
something like that
and she basically says um this bracelet
was given to me by a boyfriend like a
long time ago in europe or wherever
she's like and it's magic uh basically
what it allows you to do is that if you
kiss the bracelet
it
basically your soul or your whatever
like comes out your body and you can go
into other people's bodies and like live
as them and like feel everything they
feel and think every like know what
they're thinking and stuff but they
don't know that you're in there you know
what i mean so that's why the book's
called body rides and like i said the
cover of it let me say i think i dropped
it on the floor yeah it did so the cover
of it like this
cover like pretty much has nothing to do
with anything this is just like a very
very generic but yeah so basically the
whole setup is this bracelet
allows you to like float you can kind of
float around like loose too like you
know i mean just your soul is like
wishing around but if you don't go into
a body quickly enough like eventually
like your body will kind of like like
swoosh you back you know me and you can
only go so far there's like a distance
there's all these rules and so like
elise tells them all this is like you
know don't pop into like dead people
don't just like it's probably not a good
idea to like pop into somebody you love
because they would probably like think
some [ __ ] that you didn't want to know
or you would find it's like invading
their privacy i'm kind of like well it's
invading everybody's privacy i don't
really know if i would want to do this
but i could see how some people would
like so you could pop into somebody
else's body and they don't like i said
they don't know that you're in there and
you can hear everything they think and
feel what they're feeling and all this
other kind of stuff so of course he
doesn't believe her but she's kind of
like well i'll prove it to you just kiss
the bracelet and then he goes inside of
her then he knows that she's like
telling the truth and everything and
he's like oh wow well you know i can't
take this this is like magic so
why are you giving it to me and she's
like no for real like you saved my life
i'd be dead now if it wasn't for you so
you can have it so finally she convinces
him to take it now as i said i'm gonna
spoil this because this book is batshit
insane
so this first part like i said is really
good it's like a like i said it has like
a lot of erotic elements and like this
this dude is just kind of like thinking
like an adolescent boy all the time he
seriously can't do anything like this
poor woman is like being tortured and
killed and all he could think about is
ooh nice boobies you know what i mean
it's it's that kind of thick
i'm like this is why men should run [ __ ]
this is what's going through their minds
all the time it's like look it's a life
and death situation but ooh titties look
over there it's just kind of like that
it just so that just kind of like
cracked me up about this whole thing
this book is ridiculous if you go into
it like knowing that it's ridiculous
then you'll probably have a good time
with it it's fun but the middle part is
kind of a drag which i'll get into in a
minute but um it's like the beginning
and the end are good though but like i
said it's it's kind of ridiculous so he
has the bracelet and uh so he leaves
and then he decides
that he goes back to this the site where
he initially saved her like where he
shot the dude
and he sees to his chagrin that the dude
that he thought that he had shot dead he
totally he wasn't sure how many times he
hit him he said i think i hit him three
times and i for sure like hit him in the
head so and he was just laying there
like they kind of looked at him and he
was like yeah he looks dead to me or
whatever but then when he goes back to
that site again uh the dude is gone
so he's like well [ __ ] me uh now what
now what it's like you know so now he
like kind of knows who he is because i
think he dropped his business card or
some [ __ ] like that so he so the guy
like knows where he is so he's like well
[ __ ] well he's probably going to come
after me now because i shot him and then
he thinks to himself oh [ __ ] he might go
back after elise because he knows where
she lives too because she said that he
that the dude actually like kidnapped
her from her house so he obviously knew
where she lived and like took her to
this like other location so he decides
that it will be quicker like he has he's
like the most indecisive dude ever and
he's so he's like in the car and he's
kind of like
now well he's like outside he's like
well [ __ ] should i like actually drive
back to elise's house and make sure
she's okay because what if the killer
came back after her or should i just do
the bracelet and like you know fly over
there would that be quicker
so he decides to do
uh the bracelet thing and then he ends
up going back to elise's house and it
turns out that the killer absolutely did
go back to her house to finish her off
and he totally like tortured her and
she's already dead so it's too late for
him to save her so obviously he feels
like super really bad about it even if
he i mean even if he'd gone there like
without the brace like if he'd gone
there in bodily form because there's one
thing too is like if you put the
bracelet on and then you go and ride
somebody like do a body ride and your
soul is outside your body like your body
is just kind of it's not dead or
anything but you're just laying there
like you're kind of a sleeper like in a
coma or whatever so it's good if
i it's kind of like a buddy you need a
buddy system is what i'm saying because
somebody needs to like watch your
[ __ ] body like while you're out
flying around and so nothing bad happens
to your body
um also if somebody pulls the bracelet
off
it like breaks the link and you just pop
back into your body like immediately
like i said there's all these kind of
like rules about it and it's weird
because they don't really
he doesn't really go into like where the
bracelet came from or why it works or
i'm not saying that you have to i'm just
saying that you know and basically it's
it's almost just kind of like i don't i
don't know if i'd necessarily call it a
mcguffin but it's because it's not
really that but it does like factor into
the plot and they do use it but
it's just kind of like a whatever
technology you know what i mean where
it's just kind of like we i needed
something that people could pop from
body to body because that's kind of what
he wanted to do so he's like oh a
bracelet that's let's roll with that and
we're not going to explain why it works
or where it came from or no mythology
behind it or anything like that it's
just a thing and it exists and it's the
only one apparently and uh and you can
use it so that's kind of how it goes
so he's like really upset about elise
getting killed and then he thinks to
himself well [ __ ] i was in her house uh
before she got killed so i can't really
go to the cops because
they'll think i did it
and uh he actually did see the dude that
did it sort of like he didn't get a good
look at his face he actually starts
calling him rasputin because he's like
this really skinny dude that he's always
wearing like leather pants and he has
like this big like bushy beard and like
this big long hair and everything and
also because he shot him like three
times and then he just like wandered off
apparently and uh you know was able to
like actually go back to elise's house
and do some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] to her
so obviously
uh you know he uh he was still
okay enough to do that so now he's like
well [ __ ] i can't go to the cops and now
the dude is probably gonna come after me
so
what am i gonna do so he actually tells
his girlfriend marta like when she comes
home he tells her about elise and he
tells her about not being able to save
her and all this other kind of stuff he
does not tell her about the bracelet but
he does tell her about the other [ __ ] um
you know he kind of like finagles the
story a little bit
so uh at some point like
this is so weird this is what i mean
it's like where this is like weird
decisions
so
prior to i can't remember this is like
prior to like he tells marta his
girlfriend about [ __ ] but then like she
goes back to work and he's like well i'm
gonna stay at your apartment because you
know the killer knows where i live and
it's like if he comes back there he'll
[ __ ] me up and he doesn't know you so
i'm gonna stay here so she so he stays
there and then even though he's worried
that a killer is after him even though
he's sad because this woman that he fell
in love with in five minutes got
horribly tortured and murdered
um he decides hey i'm gonna [ __ ] around
with this bracelet some more
so he puts the bracelet on and then he
starts flying around
to he ends up in the
in the body of like this girl that
there's this woman that lives in his
apartment complex i guess
and so he basically like he gets inside
her while she's like reading some like a
smutty book or something and he's like
getting all turned on by it so this is
so it's like stereotypes like i said
it's it's more like erotica i guess than
but it's like a crime thriller too like
but that happens but it's just like a
bizarre i don't know it's so bizarre so
so he does that kind of stuff and then
because he is an idiot he's in her for a
while and then like she starts acting
really weird and like uh getting upset
about somebody and somebody named darren
or something like that i think her
name's karen yeah because their name's
rhymed and so
he's kind of like weirded out but then
he's like so intrigued that he's like
you know what i should do even though
it's like one o'clock in the morning and
i'm kind of traumatized because i just
witnessed a horrible murder and shot a
dude i'm gonna go over to this girl's
house in person even though she doesn't
know me from adam
and i've just been inside her body and
felt all her thoughts and stuff like
that and it's like i'm not that's not
weird at all it's like why is that such
a stupid idea so he decides that he's
gonna go to this girl's apartment even
though it's like the middle of the night
and so he does that and he goes there in
person
and
he basically lies to her and says oh i'm
a friend of darren's
and he told me about you and i wanted to
meet you and i know it's the middle of
the night blah blah and again very
unrealistically she's like oh okay i'll
let you in
even though this is a complete and total
stranger uh who says that he know and
see he thinks that darren is her
boyfriend but then it turns out that
like it's her brother and then like she
had some kind of incesty thing going on
with because she cuz he kind of caught
her thoughts or whatever and he didn't
realize that it was a brother and then
like he said something about it and then
it was like this big awkward thing and
then like she jumped on him and
scratched him and then he ended up
punching her in the stomach
and it's just like
and i'm sitting there going this dude
should not have this bracelet should not
have this amazing technology because
look is the idiotic [ __ ] and all that
like elise the poor woman that got
murdered that gave it to him um you know
yeah he saved her life for like five
minutes because she ended up getting
killed later which wasn't really his
fault but because he did think he shot
the dude but
then like she had all these rules like
don't do this with a bracelet i don't
you know don't i don't advise that and
all this other kind of stuff and he like
immediately starts doing like stupid
[ __ ] with it which you know maybe is
maybe that is realistic i'm not really
sure but it's like it's hard to it's
hard to root for the guy and it's hard
to understand
why every single woman that he meets is
immediately like oh hey you seem okay
let's have sex or let's fall in love or
yeah you can come in my apartment even
though i don't know who you are and then
you just showed up at my house in the
middle of the night with this weird ass
story it's just so so bizarre it's like
like i said every woman in this like
does something that no women in their
right mind would ever do
so yeah so he ends up punching this one
in the stomach and then because he has
all these scratches on his arms that
karen gave him during this fight
um you know while they were struggling
he decides well i don't want marta
seeing that because then i'll have to
explain the whole situation with karen
and like what the [ __ ] was was that even
about so he decides he's gonna go on the
lamb
so what he does is he leaves a note for
marta in her apartment and basically
says well you know i can't really go to
the cops and the killer might be after
me and i don't want him coming after you
and like finding out where i'm at so i'm
just gonna like take off and i'm not
gonna tell you where i'm going so then
like the middle part of the book
is basically like a rom-com road trip
movie because he decides for whatever
reason because i just be for plot
convenience he's really into theme parks
and he's like well i can't go to any of
the ones in california because they're
too uh they're not far enough away or
something like that so he decides he's
gonna go to i think nevada and go to
this sort of like obscure
theme park like called the fort which i
guess is kind of like a custer's last
stand themed kind of whatever even
though that didn't happen in nevada so
whatever but i don't know if it's a real
place or not it might be so he decides
he's going to go there for whatever
reason and hide out for a few days now
on the way there he stops at like some
diner like a random diner someplace
and meets
an 18 year old waitress named sue
who again
immediately falls in love with him and
even though all he does literally is
like eat breakfast there she's basically
like he's basically like yeah i'm going
to the fort like this theme park she's
like i'm coming with you and he's like
okay
so they
so she just leaves again with this
random ass stranger this random ass
stranger now at first she's not he's not
gonna like tell her about the bracelet
but then
again in a very plot conveniency kind of
way she puts it on because she thinks
it's pretty and then for whatever reason
she starts rubbing it like on her face
like in a way that no human would do and
ends up kissing it accidentally
and then so she figures out what it does
it is not all that alarmed by it she's
kind of like oh you can pop in other
people's bodies that's neat so then she
starts thinking about
like ways that they can make money with
it like can we go to vegas and all this
other stuff and none of that ever like
pans out
but so again so the basically the whole
middle part of the book is like this
road trip they don't really use the
bracelet all that much except for you
know doing sex [ __ ] like you know i'm
going to go in your body and see what
it's like happening yeah that's like
really weird and so but yeah like the
middle part there's no and i'm like did
you forget that there's like a murderer
after you and like the cops because like
the elise the woman that got killed at
the beginning she's like married to kind
of a famous dude so her getting
butchered in her house is kind of like a
big deal it's like all over the news and
everything like that and so but he seems
to like not worry but it's like nope i
just got this 18 year old waitress and
even though i have a girlfriend and i'm
just kind of i now i fell in love with
this girl and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so then like the whole middle part
of the book is that and at that point i
think at that point i was just kind of
like what the [ __ ] am i actually reading
like where is this going what happened
to the murderer what happened to all the
crime [ __ ] like that was pretty cool and
what happened to all the body jumping
because there's really not much of it
like in the middle part of the book
so finally um you know after they spend
three days together and fall in love
forever you know and marta is kind of
like he calls her and tells her about it
but then kind of lies
and then she's mad understandably but
then
they three days pass they come back to
la
and then the three of them like marta
and sue meet each other
and basically like instantly oh now
we're a threesome like marta is totally
okay with it she's like sue is so
awesome yeah we're all gonna like share
neil because he's like the best and i'm
just kind of like what okay
that's what i mean that's why i said i
had to spoil this because it's [ __ ]
it's crazy
so yeah she's not mad or nothing he's
basically like yeah i banged her and
she's 18. and then bart is just like
okay well let's all bang her and then
we'll just have this whole and i'm just
like i'm pretty sure that never went
like that like in the history of the
universe it's like he didn't even like
warner ahead of time he just showed up
with her and she's just kind of like
okay we're doing this we're like that
we're the dream team now so finally like
the three of them
they find out
that by using the bracelet in various
ways they find out that the um that the
killer you know that they've nicknamed
rasputin they find out what his real
name is like by being inside his head
and they find out that he has indeed
been back at neil's apartment like
looking for him and he does does totally
want to kill him and then they also find
out too that it was like elise's
husband who paid
uh rasputin to kill her uh so that's
what they find out so they're trying so
again there's another thing too where
they're just kind of like well we can't
call the cops they can't call the cops
they never
literally never ever call the cops in
the whole entire thing despite like some
really really [ __ ] up [ __ ] happening
they decide that they're gonna just do
this by themselves using the bracelet
and so the two women basically like put
on bikinis and go over to the actor's
house and like try to get information
out of him and then they try to like
he's um gonna pay off the killer and
they're trying to like steal the money
because it's like half a million dollars
so they go into this like big like crime
shenanigans and pretty much like almost
get themselves killed like a million
times like i said without the police
getting involved because there's this
whole thing i guess richard layman is
not really uh
i don't know he's like not a big fan of
calling the cops or he has a big thing
of la it's like oh we can't call the
cops because
you know they'll put you in jail just
for defending yourself and i'm just like
i don't i don't know if that's true but
okay so so he had excuses like through
the whole book like why they couldn't
call the cops and why they had to do all
this dumb [ __ ] themselves so but they
they consistently make like really
really stupid decisions
and just do the stupidest things to like
to get themselves in hotter and hotter
water um and they just like use the
bracelet in like really dumb ways and
it's just it's a ridiculous ridiculous
book but that said
it's still
pretty entertaining um i feel like it
could have been a lot shorter because
that whole middle section with the theme
park and him falling in love with the 18
year old waitress and then them coming
back and the other girl from being
totally okay with it um and being like
yeah let's all just jump in bed together
it just reads so much like adolescent
male fantasy to me and it's just like
but it's funny so if you go into it with
that mindset of just thinking it's gonna
be this ridiculous unbelievable these
three idiotic characters doing idiotic
things which no person in their right
mind would do in real life then you
might have a good time with it like i
said it could have been a lot shorter
it's pretty long it's like 500 or 600
pages might be almost 600 pages and i
kind of feel like the whole middle part
was like not necessary um you know it
could have just been him but could have
been just like the killer because it
almost kind of felt like the whole
middle part where he was like him and
sue were falling in love at the theme
park it kind of felt like the he forgot
that the killer existed or
i don't know it was just like a weird
digression
and it kind of like slowed the pace down
but you know when it go when it got back
to the killer part it was actually
pretty good um even though it's like i
said totally not believable and they
make like a bunch of really dumb
decisions i did actually sort of i'm not
sure if i liked the ending or not maybe
i won't spoil the ending but the ending
was kind of ballsy in the sense that i
wasn't like expecting it but then
i don't know it got kind of weird at the
end but like the implications of it are
kind of weird and it did have something
to do with the body ride type of thing
and um people
like not jumping into dead bodies and
and what happens if your body dies and
all this other kind of stuff so i did
kind of like that but yeah this was a
strange one and i did kind of feel like
i read a lot of reviews on goodreads and
just like most of his other books
i feel like it had like a lot of like
four and five star reviews but then
there were some people that were like
that were even really into richard
layman's books that were kind of like
yeah this is like his worst one this one
like sucked so bad and a lot of the
criticisms they have were a lot of the
same criticisms that i had where they
just the characters were completely
unbelievable when he was inside
uh like when neil would jump inside a
woman's head like the [ __ ] that she was
thinking was not anything like a woman
would ever think and it just seemed like
the main thrust of the plot like was
forgotten for a long time just so he
could like describe nipples some more um
of like every single woman and it's just
see i'm like this dude is like [ __ ]
distractible as hell man it's like every
time a set of nipples walks by he just
like loses his [ __ ] he just like forgets
what he was thinking about you know what
i'm saying
it's just like i don't know it was just
it's funny it was funny to me not
particularly scary um you know but if
you like kind of smutty crime thrillers
that have like a weird wedged and
rom-com in the middle then uh you might
kind of dig this and like i said the the
cover has nothing to do with anything in
the book so don't let the cover like uh
you know think it's gonna be like that
because it's not anything like that and
like i said um you know his he's known
for his stuff being richard lane and his
own first step being like really gory
and
stuff like that this doesn't really have
a lot of that it does have some kind of
nasty torture
uh toward the end but
it's not described as much as i thought
some of his other stuff was you know i
mean like a lot of it he kind of kept
implied which
so in a lot of ways like the violence
and the gore in this one it's there but
it's like a lot more restrained than
usual but then like the sexual stuff is
just kind of like crazy out there this
like i said this sounds very much like
a young guy's like very very very
specific
sexual fetish um and he wrote like a 600
page book about it that's ex that's like
the vibe that i got and
like this and come out tonight i was
like does he really have he must have
really had a thing for
being like uh you know finding a naked
woman who's just been attacked and like
saving her and then her being so
grateful that she's basically like
yeah you know hump me even though i've
just been like horribly raped and
tortured it's like because come out
tonight kind of had that vibe too
so like i said it's very specific it's
very specific and weird like fetish i'm
not judging i'm just saying uh but yeah
so not one of the better books that i've
read this year but it was fun enough
that i kind of kept it going to the end
because honestly when i kept reading it
i was just kind of like what i don't
even know where this is going or what
the [ __ ] is even happening right now so
in a way it's ridiculousness kind of
worked in its favor because i was just
kind of like let's see what the [ __ ]
else happens next let's see whose
nipples like walk by directly or
whatever so it's like so i did have fun
with it it wasn't boring that's for sure
middle part was a little bit boring but
uh but the front but the the beginning
and end were like pretty fun so i had a
good time with it um but it's not like
great literature or anything like that
it's just like kind of a fun
smutty
book with some violence in it and sort
of a killer uh but you know that's
what whatever it is what it is uh so
yeah
if any of you have read it or if you've
read any of the other richard lehman
stuff i'm dying to talk about this with
somebody because it's i don't know it's
just one of the weirdest things i've
ever read um but yeah so let me know in
the comments and uh we'll have a
discussion about it try to think up some
more names for nipples
in in richard layman's honor and uh yeah
so that'll do it for this book review uh
my tomes of terror show and i will see
you guys on the next one bye